celeste is with us she's going to start
off this hour
in tucson arizona hi celeste how are you
hi i'm doing well how are you guys
better than i deserve how can we help
that's great um so really quickly to the
point well first of all thank you for
all that to do and thank you for having
me on
um so to the point i am at a very
very toxic work environment right now um
so i'm kind of just what you were
talking about you know i get up and i
don't want to go to work
i get up and i'm i'm dreading going i
hate being there it's
gotten to the point that i just want to
quit and i'm not a quitter so it's a
very difficult time and
like season of my life right now um
however they do pay for school
and so i'm four classes away from
getting my bachelor's
however this past i'm supposed to
graduate in may um
and i just you know a lot of things a
series of events just happened and it
didn't happen for me
i'm now at the point where i'm stuck at
this job until
october 26 there's no um transferring
for me there's no
moving up nothing i was initially only
there because they paid for school but
at this point i just
i need something that's going to make me
happy i have the money to pay
for my summer classes however i'm
i'm trying to pay everything off i
finish baby step one and i don't want to
continue
using the money that i'm saving to pay
for school when
i have school paid for if i stay here
but i
i don't know what to do what is the
nature
of the toxicity what's the problem
with this um i i just
i don't grow i have no growth um
that's not time support that's not toxic
there's no support
that's not toxic okay what's toxic
there's no support and you're not
growing you're in a dead-end job it's
boring
whoop-dee-doop-dee that ain't toxic
okay so tell me what tell me what's
toxic is somebody
is there sexual things going on or
people yelling and screaming
and cussing or is somebody throwing
things at you
um are they you know discriminating
against you in some way
i mean what what's toxic
well no it's not all of that no you're
right but it is
it's no one speaks to me i go and i say
good morning no one talks to me
but that's you know that is me
complaining i should just go and do my
job that's what i'm there for
however there's just no support i can't
i can't
go talk to someone they're not letting
me know they're not asking me hey like
how are you and i don't know if that's
maybe me just complaining but no
no i'd like to go to it listen the job
sucks yeah
okay i don't i don't have any doubt i
mean you're kind of like it sounds like
office space the movie you know
yeah celeste first of all dave's asking
the right question we want to get to the
the source of toxicity so that you can
get the right frame of mind
uh but i'm going to tell you right now
you're dealing with something that
happens in offices all across
the country and all across the world and
you're just underappreciated
people want to know am i seen am i
valued and that's not fun and dave's
right it sucks
but let's reframe your perspective all
right let's just go through this very
quickly
you're four classes away from getting
the bachelor's which is why you took the
job so what's the new timeline if you
stay at this company so they pay for the
foreclosure
is that what i heard october october
26th what
october 26th okay great so i'd hang in
there until october 26th this is an
attitude change
this is hey i'm grateful for this really
boring place
because this boring place has given me
the opportunity to step up to the next
rung on the ladder in life
what you're learning here is how never
to lead when you have the opportunity
yes you have anti-mentors
they're teaching you how not to do crap
yeah and you know but but if they're not
being nasty to you
or breaking the law or you know
asking you to do something that's
immoral or
that kind of stuff uh then it's just a
matter of they
they it's a dead end job it's boring and
they're not the nicest bunch of people
in the world they don't they're not very
friendly if that's the whole version of
toxicity
you stick this out you suck it up and
stick it out
get your mind on the future pay for it
then no i have the money to pay for it i
just
i don't want to because i'm trying to
save my money i'm trying to pay off my
debt i'm only eleven thousand dollars
stay on the baby steps stay stay with
what you're doing
yes let them pay for it and finish it's
it's listen
it's par you know you're going to school
and i can guarantee you you've gone to
some classes that are taught by a
tenured professor
who's boring as crud and not a very good
teacher
and that desk hurts by the time you get
out of it
i've sat in those stupid classes
and you're doing you're putting up with
that toxic stuff
in quotes in order to get a degree in
order to further your life
you're delaying the pleasure you're
putting up with some pain to win
later does that make sense it does i
just feel like i'm delaying
the the chance to leave this job if i
were to just pay for if you can leave
the job and someone will give you a job
that pays for your
education that's all thrilling and they
affirm you every day
have at it i'm actually going to push
back celeste i don't think you're
delaying your exit from this boring job
you're del if you leave you're delaying
getting into the next baby step don't
use that money when
they they're gonna pay you how old are
you
i just turned 24. how many brothers and
sisters do you have
i'm an older brother and a younger
brother you're the middle
yes okay
interesting all right i yeah i i still
i um you can do whatever you want you're
a grown person if you want to quit and
spend your money
but basically you are writing a check in
order to get away from these people
that's what you're doing and i i don't
hear anything here that's worth writing
a check for
um you know 68 of americans are
dissatisfied at work is that right
it's absolutely right close to 80 and so
that means that
uh at least half of those are
experiencing something along the lines
of what you
are experiencing because most people
aren't leaders most people are bosses
most organizations don't affirm most
organizations don't communicate most
organizations suck
and that's why most people don't like
working there and so
uh but toxic is when something's
happening to you that's abusive yes
and you're not being abused kiddo yeah
you're just not being affirmed and it's
dead end and it's boring
yeah you gotta change your mindset here
it's wait a second i'm
grateful for the money
to get out of to to get the schooling i
need while i'm getting out of
debt it needs to be a total shift we
know this from nurses
i worked in a place in my 20s one time
that everybody
in the building it seemed like right was
sleeping with each other
oh it was a dad gum soap opera yeah yeah
that's a nice way of saying it yeah
um and it was just nuts i mean and i'm
in the middle of this thing and i'm
going
this is gross and you know what
i was only there for about five months
before i got moved on right and and but
it was one of my first few jobs coming
out of college and you go through some
situations like that but you know what i
learned from that you know that that was
30 something years ago i'm sitting here
talking about it
what i learned from that is i'm not
going to tolerate a situation like that
but and i'm not gonna now that i'm in a
position to control it i'm gonna have a
whole bunch of people inside our
building
that are running around like it's some
kind of orgy or something yeah this is
nuts
and so people do this though in the
workplace and but not ours and you know
not there and we're not you know it's
not who we are
and so then a young lady or young man
could come to work here of character and
they can feel safe
where you know that and now that's toxic
yes but but you know but i still i i
didn't
walk out the door and quit that day i
endured it for a while but what i got
from the endurance was the lesson
to make sure it never happens in my
environment quick thing here folks we
see what we focus on
we know this they've done all types of
neuroscience studies on this when you
buy a car
you get excited about that car purchase
how many of you see it everywhere
for the first six seven days it's
because there's an intense focus on it
when you focus on being a victim
you will see victimization everywhere
you go
as opposed to going wait a second i'm so
close to being debt free
and i'm with my school paid for with a
degree and all i gotta do is put up with
boring awful leadership until october
i can do that yeah that's you gotta wait
until christmas to open your gifts too
[Laughter]
i hate that dave i do no discipline
seems pleasant at the time but it yields
a harvest of righteousness